The world I knew
was quite simple.
I didn't know
there was such a
thing as electricity.
Or that water could
come into the house
through a pipe.
I never thought about
what I looked like.
I didn't know what a mirror was!
♪♪
When you grow up
in a community
where everything you know
is powerful and good
and it's black,
there's no concept of race.
That defines Sidney Poitier.
I left The Bahamas with
this sense of myself.
And from the time
I got off the boat,
America began to say to me,
"You're not who
you think you are."
♪♪
There was a habit in Hollywood
of utilizing blacks
in the most
disrespectful ways.
I said, "I cannot play that."
I don't think Sidney ever
played a subservient part.
Never bucked his eyes,
never ducked his head.
They call me, Mister Tibbs.
Yeah!
♪♪
It was the first time I've
seen a black man
assert his power.
I'm a giant
and I'm surrounded by ants.
I wanted to marry
Sidney Poitier.
He was like, wow!
Movie stars
should be...
wow.
Biggest box office draw
Black Man 1967-68'.
And the whole
country is spiraling
around him.
We're hanging together by
a few cultural threads.
And Sidney Poitier
is one of those
cultural threads.
The winner is Sidney Poitier.
And it's not easy
being the first
when you have to
represent the entire race.
♪♪
He had big shoulders-
he was given big shoulders,
but he had to carry
a lot of weight.
If there were equality of
opportunity
in this business,
there'd be 15
Sidney Poitier's and 10 or 12
Bellafonte’s.
But there is not.
-Probably other way around.
Watch it, watch it,
watch it.
[laughs]
He was gonna put black people
in positions where
they can have a career
behind the camera.
He came to this Earth
to move it,
to change it,
to shake it.
You think of yourself
as a colored man,
I think of myself as a man.
♪♪
That's the summary of him.
I love him so much.
My life had
more than a few
wonderful,
indescribable turns.
♪♪
And I have lived them.